The human body is a complex network of
cells
tissues and
organs
that together
Make life possible
Ten major systems are responsible for the body's functions
skeletal muscular
cardiovascular
nervous
endocrine
lymphatic
respiratory digestive urinary
Reproductive
The skeletal muscular
cardiovascular and nervous systems in particular
create an infrastructure that facilitates the other systems the
Adult skeletal system is a framework of over 200 bones
They hold the body together give it shape and protect its organs and tissues
The skeleton also provides anchor points for the muscular system, which includes three types of muscles skeletal
smooth and cardiac
They are found throughout the body and facilitate movement
Nestled within these muscles is the cardiovascular system a pipeline that includes the heart blood vessels and the blood itself
also called the circulatory system the
cardiovascular system delivers oxygen white blood cells hormones and nutrients throughout the body
Lastly the nervous system is a communication network of nerve cells that the body uses to transmit information and coordinate
bodily functions
It's comprised of the brain the hub of sensory and intellectual activity the spinal cord
And the many cranial and spinal nerves that emanate from them
This infrastructure created by neurons blood muscles and bones
Allows three other systems to regulate the body's environment the endocrine lymphatic and urinary systems
The endocrine system is a series of glands that use information carried by the nervous system to help regulate the body's
processes
Thanks to this neural connection endocrine glands such as the thyroid are aware of the amount of hormones and other chemicals
They need to produce
these chemicals are then distributed throughout the body by way of the cardiovascular system the
cardiovascular and nervous systems are also utilized by the lymphatic system a
collection of lymph nodes and vessels that help regulate the body's defenses
Also called the immune system the lymphatic system uses neural pathways to transmit information
About affected areas of the body and then sends out healing agents like white blood cells via the blood stream
Another key, regulatory system is the urinary system, which includes the kidneys ureters bladder and urethra
The urinary or renal system maintains the body's electrolyte levels and filters wastes from the blood
This waste is sent through the blood vessels into the kidneys and then expelled as urine
All of these systems require energy to function and that's where the respiratory and digestive
Systems come in
The respiratory system is a group of passageways and organs that extracts life-giving oxygen from the air we breathe
Air enters the body through nasal cavities travels down the throat and is then transported to the lung
The lungs extract oxygen for the body to use and then expel a carbon dioxide by-product when we exhale energy
Can also come in the form of food?
The digestive system is an approximately 30 foot series of organs that convert food into fuel
Food enters the system through the mouth then moves into the esophagus the stomach and the intestines
Nutrients are absorbed into the body while solid waste is expelled through the anal canal the end of the digestive tract
No matter the roll size or shape of any of the body systems each began with a reproductive system
This system is responsible for creating life
the primary organs involved differ between the sexes with ovaries fallopian
Tubes the uterus and vagina found in women and testes and a sperm channel found in men together
Fertilization may occur organ systems form and then a child is born
Humans are complicated organisms
But when our 10 major organ systems are healthy
They ensure our well-being
You